Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thanks everyone
that submitted questions for this week’s
Q&A. I know a lot of you were wondering why
they didn’t talk about tainted meat from
the comic on Talking Dead.
Chris Hardwick reads the comics, he knows
what’s going on. They just avoid anything
potentially spoilery because Talking Dead
is produced by AMC and their policy is no
spoilers.
There was also some footage of Beth that leaked
online. I’m not going to post it here, just
because AMC is pulling it down everywhere.
It’s from the next couple of episodes. So
you’ll see it in next week’s episode or
at least by episode 4.
On to Questions, lots of Bob B Q going around...Careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven’t
seen it.
Question 1 - Mangese asks, do you think Bob
will tell the Hunters they ate Tainted Meat?
Question 2 - Weasel Brothers asks what about
the bible verse easter egg in
the church?
Question 3 - Jim Jam asks who’s making the
marks on the trees that Morgan saw?
Question 4 - Fleek Squad asks, How long does
it take bitten people to turn? And if Bob
was bitten and the Hunters ate his leg, will
they turn?
Question 5 - Alex asks, what’s the deal
with Maggie never talking about Beth?
(she did ask daryl in the first episode)
Question 6 - bokayjunkie Will there be Beth
Stuff this half of
the season?
Question 7 - Ana asks, wasn’t Marvin, the
guy who threatened Judith in the last scene?
The guy
Tyrese said
he killed.
Question 8 - Doru asks, do you think Abraham
will become the main villain by the end
of this season?
Question 9 - kamos asks, when sasha said 3
of us are missing in the trailer she was talking
about daryl, carol and bob right?
Question 10 - Mitchie asks why do you think
they chose Beth to get her own storyline versus
any
of
the other characters?